I want to bring up an Allied question
which is related to the Multiverse so I
want to read something to you from a
while back in Quantum magazine which uh
which talked about the study of
non-gaussianides and in Quantum magazine
they say the study of rigorous study of
non-gaussianides took off in 2002 when
wal Mal de Cena a revered monk-like
theorist at The Institute for advanced
study calculated what's known as a
gravitational floor the minimum number
of triangles and other shapes that are
guaranteed to exist in the sky due to
the unavoidable effect of gravity during
Cosmic inflation cosmologists had been
struggling to calculate the
gravitational floor for more than a
decade since it would provide a concrete
goal for experimentalists if the floor
is reached and still no triangles are
detected maltesena explained then
inflation is wrong so I want to ask you
because I don't I actually interviewed a
real monk last week and I have to say
you guys have some somewhat similar you
know countenances you're very very
revered and very reserved but I don't
know if the monk-like attribute is is
accurate but but leaving that aside
behind me are these balls I'm gonna go
get one while you're on the screen but
can you first talk a little bit about
what is a non-gaussianity in the
cosmological context and I'll bring up
some visuals for the audience while uh
an interesting fact about the universe
is that it's very close to uniform on
long distances
but and I think in fact this is not
perfectly uniform there were some
primordial inhomogeneity so it was the
first approximation homogeneous but with
tiny little ecomoginators that I guess
you've been studying for
your your career and that's a map of
those in homogeneous as we see them
through the CMB
um
this in homogeneity is believed that
they were produced through Quantum
effects they were due to Quantum
fluctuations during the beginning of
inflation
um and so they are random so the Phantom
fluctuations are random
but in quantum theory the
um
the randomness has some pattern so
so there are different patterns of
randomness
and so the simplest pattern is so called
gaussian pattern where each each region
could sort of fluctuate independently of
the others roughly speaking it's not
exactly this but
um each let's say way fluctuates
differently from the others and that's
like the simplest pattern the belt curve
the gaussian distribution
um but
in in actual theories uh actual theories
are interacting and the fluctuation in
one place creates some decreases or
increases another type of fluctuation in
a similar region so
um so you have some known gaussian
effects so some donation means that
there were some interactions between the
waves you could view this as waves or
fluctuations in the geometry of the
shape of the universe
and
we
this uh these deviations from gaussian I
think gives us very deep information
about the interactions that were present
during the inflationary times during the
times of inflation when these
fluctuations were produced
um and so the simplest interaction that
we had was interaction of gravity so
that if you have a fluctuation that
creates it's created an over density
okay it created some gravitational
potential and then some other
fluctuation would would look different
and that's this so-called gravitational
floor so it's the minimum amount of non
deviations from the gaussianity that you
would need if inflation is correct at
least or at least single phase inflation
um but in principle there could be
larger effects due to other particles
that could
could have existed during that time in
some some ways the early inflation is
like a particle detector or a particle
collider that uh you you you create all
these particles uh
what could be created so the universe at
the time was expanded rapidly and
there's an effect similar to the effect
of hoping radiation that we discussed
before that creates this Quantum effect
that creates this this waves this
younger these fluctuations
and it could also create other particles
which have mass to the effective
temperature of these equations and
they
um so if you created those particles it
could also imprint all kinds of
interesting patterns in the sky I mean
so far so far no non-gosianities were
detected so
that is uh so it's very very close to
gaussian but still there couple of
orders of magnitude to go to
to get to this floor somehow to this
minimal amount and I guess they're very
interesting experiments going on trying
to
calculate this to measure I mean to
experimentally measure this non-gaussian
it is better